use the points 0 comma 2 2 comma 8 and X
want X comma Y on the blue line in the
graph below to complete the equation and
they have this first equation y minus 2
over X is equal to blank and then they
say write the equation of the line in
the form y equals MX plus B so we have a
line here and they give us two exact
points and then they tell us one general
point in terms of X comma Y although the
way they've drawn it on the diagram it
looks like it's the point negative 3
comma negative 7 but we'll just play
this assume that we don't know what
those are that those are just two
general points and what we want to do is
figure out what this ratio is and then
we need to figure out the equation of
the line well a good place to start is
just figure out the common ratio between
our change in Y and our change in X
between any two points in the line so
let's think about that if I were to go
from point 0 comma 2 to point 2 comma 8
what's going to be my change in X so my
change in X is just like that so my
change in X is equal to well to go from
x equals 0 to x equals 2 you had to go
up 2 in the x-direction or you have to
go to the right 2 I should say in the
x-direction and our change in Y well
we're going from y equals 2 to y equals
8 so our change in Y if you're gonna go
from 2 to 8 your change in Y remember
triangle wide this literally is the
Greek letter Delta Delta Y is just a
shorthand for saying your change in Y
well I went from 2 to 8 is equal to 6 so
if you constructed a right triangle like
this this sides length is 6 this sides
length is 2 and the ratio of this height
to this base is going to be the slope of
your line so Delta Y over Delta X over
Delta X is equal to 6 over 2 which is
equal to 3 which is equal to 3 so what
do we do what do we do with this how
does this answer either of those either
of those questions
well this ratio your change in Y your
change in height versus your change in
the base right over here versus your
change in X
is going to be constant for any right
triangle constructed this way on this
line so for example when you're going
this right over here Y minus 2 over X
let's think about it a little bit more
if I were to go if I were to go from the
point X comma Y to the point right here
which is the point 0 comma 2
what would my change in X be so my
change in X is going to be equal to well
if I end up I end up at x equals 0 and I
started at X so I end up at x equals 0
and I started at X my change in X is
going to be 0 minus X and if that
doesn't make a lot of sense just think
about it if this if X is negative 3 then
our change in X is 0 minus negative 3
which is 3 the length of this side of
the triangle right over here is 3 now
let's think about the height our change
in Y our change in Y well our change in
Y we end up at a y equals 2 so it's
going to be 2 minus whatever our
original Y is minus of our original Y is
and it looks like if you just eyeball at
this point looks like it's at about
negative 7 and if you have 2 minus
negative 7 you get 9 and this indeed has
length 9 so this ratio Delta Y over
Delta X should be constant for any right
triangle constructed like this where the
hypotenuse is the line itself so Delta x
over Delta Y Delta or Delta Y I should
say Delta Y over Delta X might the ratio
of this side to this side is always
going to be the same these are all
similar triangles gonna have the same
ratio as this right over here so change
in Y is 2 minus y change in X is 0 minus
X this is going to have the same ratio
is going to be 6 2 2 or 3 2 1 or just 3
now you're saying wait Sal that still
doesn't answer my question even if I get
this 0 out of the way I could write 2
minus y is equal to negative x or 2
minus y over negative x is equal to 3
but how does this get us this ratio
right over here well if you multiply
this numerator and the
nominator by a negative sign so if you
just multiply the numerator and the
denominator by a negative sign as long
as you're doing the same to the
numerator denominator you're not
changing the value of this expression in
the numerator you'll get Y minus 2 and
in the denominator negative 1 times
negative x is X well that's still going
to be the same ratio that's still going
to be 3 so this right over here is going
to be 3 then they say write the equation
in the form y equals MX plus B so when
you have an equation in the form y
equals MX plus B this term right over
here this is that ratio we've been
dealing with this says hey every time I
increase X by some amount how much of am
i increasing Y by this is your slope
here and so we know that this is going
to be of the form we know this is going
to be of the form Y is equal to ownit in
that black color Y is equal to our slope
for this line is 3 is equal to 3x plus B
and now we have to figure out what B is
and what helps us in this is to
recognize that they've given us several
points they tell us what happens well
when x is 0 Y is 2 when X is 2 y is 8 so
we can use any one of those points to
solve for B I like using x equals 0 y
equals 2 because it cancels this term
out very nicely so we know that when X
is equal to 0 Y is 2 or we could say
when y is 2 when y is 2 or when X is
equal to 0 Y is 2 so 3 times 0 plus B is
going to be equal to 2 well that's just
a 0 and you're just left with B is equal
to 2 or 2 is equal to B so we're done
it's y equals 3x plus y equals 3x plus 2
so let's fill that in on the actual
exercise so this ratio is 3 it's the
ratio between a change in height over
our change in X that's constant across
the line when you construct a right
triangle they're all going to be similar
they're all going to have that same
ratio and then the equation of the line
in that form it's
why equals that change in Y over change
in X a constant ratio which is defined
as slope 3x + 2 - this - which is where
you intersect the y it what is the value
get when x equals 0 that's often called
the y-intercept because you see you
intersect when x is equal to 0 that's
when you intersect the y-axis so y
equals 3x plus 2 and you could verify
that any of these points will will
satisfy this equation and we got it
right